[Musique]
dynastie des qing
dans le cas où vous pendriez en cours de
route cette grande saga historique voici
un résumé des épisodes précédents
l'histoire se déroule dans une
principauté imaginaire situé à 30
kilomètres de nice à crapaud quelle
jolie frappe au jour le repos quel joli
jeu lui faire un bisou
bonjour le prince me bienfaitrice en
m'embrassant tu a rompu le sort qu'on
avait jeté sur mon berceau qu'elle est
en herbes hautes et moi je fais partie
de la dynastie des ebooks la dynastie
des boucs
quel est ton prénom nadine j'ai bien
connais ta mère
ça s'appelle un coup de foudre le prince
lui l'ue va immédiatement demandé la
main de la belle nadine amouk à son père
le roi devra partir pour jérusalem
j'ai mokhtar tu devras me ramener 2 kg
de boudin blanc dès que le prince lui
par pour jérusalem ne dîne se fait
enlever par le pesq à tort et son fidèle
akbar quel joli maclou ils l'entraînent
dans son par m aux confins du désert
sika
aussi
pendant ce temps lui arrive à jérusalem
et rencontres kassim germes ou d'un an
pucci un boudin blanc
[Musique]
achat sous les voûtes bien comme ça
pendant ce temps le pesq à tort commence
à saturer de la belle n'a dit ni mook et
essaye de la revendre le temps chambru
la gandoura et brûlis je n'ai play les
barreaux jeu c'est mon coeur je peux
plus tendus l'ouvrier français blanc de
préférence je peux plus je peux plus je
fais quelque chose tout de suite à l'eau
les bars à sion paris bien placement les
petites annonces le prince lui oublie
nadine amouk dans les bras des chats
écrasés
c'est toi la phrase qui tirait bien
celle de bachelard si je trouve plus con
que moi je veux tu pourras si tout ce
passe comme envers le disait un plus con
que toi on meurt je peux pas je peux pas
vivre avec toi je peux plus rester avec
moi alors je me casse je retourne chez
kassim avec lui au moins je pouvais
discuter avec lui au moins je pouvais
philosopher eh ben ça tombe bien parce
que je commençais ou aussi en avoir
marre claque
aïcha écrasé l'entente serait un hadji
bon d'accord ça voulait pas aux mots -
l'embrasser elle pensait à la décoration
de la maison celle là va chez ta mère
tiens elle n'aura pas eu le temps
d'aller chez sa mère à moins qu a quand
même des noms prédestinés elle tient à
riesch a écrasé sa écrasé voit surtout
d'où l'expression populaire calais
pendant la suite qu'elle fit un pierre
berger allemand est à son tour mordu
pour nadine mercier
quel joli berger allemand je vais faire
un petit bonjour les bergers allemands
bonjour et belle enfant tu sais comme
invité exactement les garder ta maison
est pâtent hamelin wamala le décor est
planté
les personnages aussi où vous êtes
maintenant fin prêt à suivre la suite de
cette grande saga la dynastie des ebooks
ne ratez pas dès samedi prochain
votre grand feuilleton quelques
dromadaires la dynastie des ebooks la
dynastie des ebooks
nous retrouvons label nadine ebooks et
son berger allemand en bolivie
péruvienne des répétitions front line et
20 minutes
hi hi hi lo à la haye
alors pu défendre et eva willemarck ça
fait 10 fois qu'on fait la même chanson
dit ce matin l'émoi de bons à rien de
dire c'est seulement qu'il a la peau de
vous connaître à la brillante bolivie
était commandant de bord de barbie sg-1
c'est que je te barbie qui combine un
but l'on nous avait été coupable on
regarde un peu derrière et à la couleur
question ses compagnons le vrai bon
c'est fait très rare que des tests
automatiques qu'elles donnent peut pas
aller contre la nature va mais leur
applique toi avez l'air il à müller - la
dynamique
maples eva muller dans que j'ai un my
league non qu'elle est basané
je retourne chez mon père le prince lui
accablé revient les mains vides chez le
roi des ebooks qui est une belle
étrangers je suis le prince lui le
promis de nadine amouk la princesse que
j'ai rencontré il ya presqu'un an tiens
ya presqu'un an en septembre
or je suis tombé follement amoureux
d'elle tout de suite j'ai été voir son
père j du monseigneur donnez moi la main
de votre fille à l'époque les besoins de
boudin blanc parce que l'approché des
fêtes de noël on arrive à envoyer à
jérusalem pour chercher du boudin blanc
la barre est humide un bloc à bernis
goualo rien du tout par contre j'ai
rencontré kassim qui m'a confié aïcha
mais j'en ai eu ras le bol parce que
c'est pas vous qui le raconte aimait les
femmes au bout d'un moment tu alors
najim elle a été enlevée pour le risque
a tort j'avais perdu sa trace et affolé
le pescador l'an voulait plus on la
retrouve à la rue du stand un jeu pas
tout vous raconter
oui c'est guy les leurs ont inventé moi
sont chômeurs a dit moi c'est tout droit
vous prenez tout droit puis après c'est
sur l'acompte juste après les cabinets
voilà
c'est marrant je pensais pas que le roi
a été aussi remarqué ça réconforte
on sent moins seul
mais si au nom il manquait plus que
celui là
[Musique]
je n'ai pas osé
j'ai tout dans les bureaux
sentimental
mais aussi ses pairs dis donc y es-tu
bel enfant de saint louis je suis nadine
amouk tu sais la fille du roi dit et toi
qu'est tubes à l'étranger je suis le
guet je suis une nouvelle le roi
embaucher un gay qu'est ce que je vais
me faire un nom
non non ce fait il pas la ville ont duré
dix ans mais ce n'est pas vraiment mon
genre de beauté moi j'aime plutôt ce qui
ce qui pique aussi
oui si j'adore ce qui pique on va bien
cinq ans oui je le fasse nous re devenir
copine en tout cas la dgid tuatara
descente et un teint de pêche tient
secrets à se créer à nouveau gel à la
personne ah non je fais le soir des
masque d'argile rouge et des infusions
de 10 euros si tu te fais ce qu'il me
faudrait donc là c'est pas terrible base
toute la journée dans cette tour au
soleil si vous allez au lit toute la
journée duo sonné ben oui forcément le
guet le guéguette oublie ça soit guérido
et il va pas être facile le passage du
nom s'est pas toujours papa ben écoute
il est très occupé en ce moment ce
vraiment pleinement mais s'être mal
gérés quelque chose d'urgent lui dire je
m'en fous que j attends et mordit l'oeil
toral plus
sympathique non
que je devrais pouvoir il ya si
longtemps mais moins d'eau je suis par
divers nouvelle aventure j'ai dans les
paroles parce qu'à tort je suis parti en
amérique du sud
bref je te raconte pas tout tout ce que
je peux te dire faire tu m'as pas prêter
d'argent depuis le printemps dernier
j'ai complètement fauché j'ai des dettes
peux-tu me dépanner papa non je suis
encore plus content que la télévision
régionale je t'en prie et moi sans
compter que j'attends toujours mon reçu
de la dernière fois on est papa juin je
me battrai pour le rendre je te rendre
tout en argent des panneaux à faire un
petit peu
non non ça va ça va ça va encore un
petit panneau l'entretien il ya
quelqu'un pour toi qui va peut-être
temps donné la monsieur tu as tort non
au ballon et m'ont reçu jean pour moi ne
tend pas pas en j'adore quand ça défile
comme ça et l'ambiance en ce moment ça
me rappelle dallas suis ici en fin de
salon
pourtant je n'ai pas froid ou vous
bonjour loulou
[Musique]
paris tout est magie voilà voilà
à agir majeur
merlin chanteur et je lis met à chanter
je vais rouler une pelle su le faire un
bisou bonjour mr là le chanteur tu es là
tu me manques
oui nate et des moufles de présente mon
fidèle assistant avant histoire
zizou l'assistante vers la halle
chanteur zizou est gelé ses sous je vais
faire un bisou au jour le 6 août
nadine oui tu la princesse qui embrasse
oui là denim ou cloud et auquel plaisir
de rencontrer une âme charitable pour te
récompense et je vais te changer ta
petite trombi ça si je chantais tient
procès là
abracadabra corps nous occuperons poum
tchak
monsieur tomber dans la formule la
recommencer c'est tout
cornes de bouc préservatif en bois
bonbons de charte
qualité déjà la formule préservatif en
bois le préservatif à boire
ah oui c'est comme ça mais celui-là pas
de pitié
salut les cartes vermeil vous avez pas
vu par hasard
naji limoux qu ma promise 4 le prince le
bonnet ou arrangé les choses
le prince le juge a lui retrouvé je la
tiens jacques un préservatif hautbois
cor ne s'occupe chaque oman à jean aux
femmes en beauté
la dynastie des ebooks résumé des
épisodes précédents rien ne va plus chez
les hiboux label din imoca fuyant le
pallec son père arrive en pleine forêt
où elle rencontre merlin le chanteur
paul amar un chanteur quel joli mais un
chanteur je lui faire un bisou
bonjour les nouveaux acheteurs publics
pour chaque il va transformer la grève
d'une certaine catégorie de personnel
notamment grève des services de
décoration des scénaristes des
costumiers et d'une grève tournante des
musiciens nous n'avons pas été en mesure
de vous présenter la dynastie des ebooks
dans des conditions idéales
nous espérons vous donner satisfaction
la semaine prochaine guy môquet julie
boch et recherche le principal atout que
va-t-il se passer
pendant ce temps dans la forêt le prince
lui et nadine sont véritablement
désappointé va pas rester comme ça
exactement toi au moins et moi en toi
qu'allons-nous faire l'élu allons voir
les couilles
[Rires]
dynastie des ebooks résumé des épisodes
précédents
la princesse nadine amouk et le prince
lui victime des sortilèges de merlin le
chanteur cherche une solution pour
retrouver leur apparence normale je peux
pas rester comme ça bouge pas on va les
vérifier
dépouillé je crois que j'ai fermement
dit c'est bien on va quand même essayer
donc j'ai ma mère est là rien n'a rien
[Musique]
mesdemoiselles
nous allons aujourd'hui aborder la leçon
27 chapitres 49/100 les doigts de ton et
maman soit propre
je compte sur votre vigilance le
syndicat a toujours raison de ceux du
quart toujours raison qu'est ce que vous
voulez vous savez pas lire
c'est fermé le mardi il faut toujours
obéir aux syndicats il faut toujours
vous nous écoutez nous crottes
il ne faut pas oublier de payer ses
cotisations au syndicat nous pouvons
oublier de payer ses cotisations
syndicales
paulino reset ces thèmes où vous me
reprenait tout ça plus fort s'il vous
plaît il ne faut pas pauline il ne faut
pas payer ses cotisations au syndicat du
silence on veut retrouver notre
apparence à vous les transformez aux 800
me nous allez les filles le 127 chapitre
42 faudrait pas qu'elle ait fait ce prix
je les connais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
résumé des épisodes précédents
la princesse madeleine et mouk et le
prince menu durent attendre le mercredi
pour retrouver leur tendance normale
quelle ne fut pas leur choix thomas
temps à faire la maintenance y être
coquette et ben tu sais en tout cas je
peux te dire que je suis rassuré parce
que c'est bon a dit sue plus à l'aise
comme ça un moindre avec mabri apparence
est comme ça où on allait jusqu'à moi
qui personnellement une vivacité bien
contente aussi d'être un garçon parce
que ça m'a fait beaucoup réfléchir le
psychologue
oui non mais tu le vois que reste quand
même en gardant sw pas naturel
le tabou du oui c'est ce qui se passe ça
va donner à réfléchir et je me suis dit
tiens nadine pourquoi je serai pas tout
aussi libéré âgées
[Musique]
les accueillait son sens dad je la
connais libérez libérez envie d'être
libéré de certaines ficelles de 3 celle
d'en bas comme un félin quoi je te dire
quelque chose
maintenant on ce lundi dans un an deux
ans d'accord on a un enfant
ton père il faut bien garder le coach et
un soir sur deux et nous on est libéré
simon tirman je vais te verrai la crise
elles sont sorties soit besoin de taper
son parent financièrement les finances
tu veux dire aux français je pense à
travailler pour récupérer ses pattes ou
presque grâce à d'ailleurs toxicologue
quand tu me rappelles aïcha écrasé que
j'ai bien connue et je sais comment il a
fini c'était celle aïcha a travaillé un
jour je te parlerai 2 1 non à l'union
revient des choses sérieuses tulipes
boxé par honda bonbons un délicieux
regardez vous le dire je te crois que
j'ai trouvé du travail au frère manu
tortionnaires travail bien payé
mi-temps se présenter chez le marquis de
fade to grey samedi manutentionnaire tu
vas savoir faire le manutentionnaire toi
j'ai parce que c'est lui mais ça va rien
marquer tu vas tu sais qui c'est alger
compris mon père le tronçon et les
pierres et les fiers
[Musique]
la dynastie des ebooks
cette fois ci c'est sur la princesse
nagui l'inouk est bien décidé à
travailler
[Musique]
vers là pour manu tortionnaires parce
que c'est la langue nos tortionnaires
bien payés travaillent temps complet ou
mis en joie
je veux y aller vraiment ou plus jusqu'à
sûr il le faut je sais que je peux
subvenir à des besoins non écoute
regarde c'est ici je vais pas y aller
alors justement voilà pourquoi je
connais brestois placement il y avait
tout ça j'ai tant prix vous soit une
femme indépendante déjà la part du bénin
et on chante du basque aux ivoiriens
[Musique]
oui
je m'excuse mais qui dit
de chercher martine tu as devant toi a
marqué deux fois que je les marque pages
de lui faire un bisou
bon je dois marquer de padt si je lui
signé 10 dans la mijaurée alors été sur
un article tombe voisine mais j'ai plus
que dit comme ça dida elle est à combien
la culotte dans la dette c'est 250 250
dinars d'ide en l'écoutant regarder
[Musique]
c'est ravissant c'est quelque chose qui
te branche
écoutez si je me laissais faire châtré
touche 3dmax me vient pourquoi et du
mois tu recherches quelque chose est
sûre je recherche la petite annonce
manutentionnaire je viens peau j'ai
envie d'être une famille je vous le dis
franchement tout à tuer pour l'annoncer
reprocher j'ai remarqué c'est la non ce
qui est intéressant
alors ça consiste en quoi cette petite
année sur ma fille tu penses que tu
pourras faire la terre déjà été servi au
château de papa j'en ai vu plein tu
aimes le cuir tchad dans jeanne
gimontois le pire c'est qu'il faut
drastique et j'ai vu le faire savoir
moi je serai style sera atypique qui est
mastiquée ex
puisqu'on est servante com frontpage c
kom sa numéro
les bretelles à se libérer des griffes
du pervers marquis de sade
vous le saurez en regardant le prochain
épisode de la dynastie des qing
la dynastie des mondes la princesse
naimi mook est finalement rentré au
service du marquis de sade mais le
prince lui inquiet est sur ses gardes
décide d'aller la chercher mais je crois
que j'arrive à temps un alors la voilà
la demeure du marquis de fans
ynwa pourquoi de montceau
dis moi pourquoi tu m'en soucie
on va
de la vie
ben
mais quand bien
[Musique]
matin
et toulouse
oh
non
je ne
e
ça
[Musique]
nadine la dénie book la bb bon on aimait
de m tu es gentil tu va te changer tout
de suite tu veux mettre ta culotte
rapide à aix et tu va nous servir à
table
j'attends un invité jean-marie koala
navire lire des ebooks je veux bien
matraque et l'automatisme il n'est pas
du tout question que je serve à table
mais non je raconte pas le voir et en
plus toi tu vas tu devenue commune chic
molle je m'ennuie avec toi mais je
préfère te donner ma démission je te
quitte lens je vais redevenir méchant
que maman qui a écoute bien su tout de
suite espèce de chien
je ne crois pas gérard collomb nadine
jean jeu que je tenais bien je suis tout
de suite que tu fais ce que je fais là
on l'a échappé belle
tu sais ce que c'est que le marquis de
sade j'étais alors c'est qui sympathique
gala se coiffe indique n'a pas fais et
des culottes en latex
bon je tape en chutant face à l'ensemble
un bon tu me suis bien c'est pas facile
d'en bas
[Musique]
ah ah
la dynastie des ly me résumé des
épisodes précédents
le prince lui lui volant au secours de
la princesse n'a dit ni mook fait une
chute spectaculaire en s'échappant de la
forteresse dumas lui tant qu'elle est a
tué c'est pas si il est importante pour
lui les chutes shellback qui te ferait
quand même pu temps passé qu'est ce que
tu vas faire maintenant mais je vais
aller au centre héliomarin hier pour me
retaper un peu ils vont voir si j'ai pas
des séquelles c'est le centre des stars
là bas lui yvan voir surtout si je peux
rester gagner comme ça toute ma vie
changera pas beaucoup tout en
plaisantant tout cas je l'attaquerai
parce que c'est pas possible qui me
poussait à 60 à leur comédie par tout un
ensemble c'est au moins 130 je l'attends
justice la raison lui puis comme s'en
prendre à un petit peu de blé depuis ne
fais pas de soucis value j'ai promis que
j'allais travailler je vais aller
travailler
je subvenir à nos besoins tu fais pas de
souci j'y vais tout de suite d'ailleurs
[Musique]
c'est la personne la bourse ou la vie je
veux bien la gauche si j'allais vivre je
suis encore tombé sur une enclume
je suis mort n des bois le justicier
sauvage pour moi j'ai envie d'embrasser
sur la bouche et un bijou qu'est ce que
tu fais je suis le justicier son ouvrage
je vois le vent les pauvres pour donner
aux riches mois les corrige
lui c'est petit robert l'intellectuel du
groupe ares
et allez voter breloque si c'est pas
supposer que tu as là d'aller voler les
pauvres pour donner aux riches
j'ai des dettes à mon père et moi je
veux bien travailler avec toi j'ai plein
d'adressent de peau ne sommes pas les
seuls pas et on y va mais il arrive vers
la forêt j'ai accepté dans le groupe je
vais faire pousser une poussée coup et
aulas et travaille aujourd'hui à dieu
stop à thatcher il faut travailler
j'ai une banque centrale voler les
pauvres tout de suite et en plus j'ai
même des bijoux
allez vas y tu sais faire l'amour il
gasquet on avait carrément bien le mien
le dico amondji la princesse nadine
amouk saura-t-elle faire la bourride
vous le saurez en regardant le prochain
épisode de la dynastie des plumes ou qu
ils sont vraiment obsolète tous les deux
obsolète
adjectif qualificatif démodé hors
d'usagé
ouah page 48 la dynastie des ebooks
résumé des épisodes précédents c
la princesse nadine amouk est acceptée
dans le clan demeure un des bois avec
lui elle se met au travail
puis elle est pauvre mais d'abord les
trouver
[Musique]
non
là pour ça ou la vie voilà qui est bien
est ce que je suis content bien toi
qu'on les cherche c'est le monde
on en parle beaucoup de ces nouveaux
pauvres mais on les voit pas souvent
nouveau pauvre petit robert nouveau port
apparaissent en général au cours d'une
crise économique
voir page 30 tout de même ça suffit le
dico en route pour de nouvelles
aventures mais avant ça suffit regarde
là bas encore notre endroit j'étais
encore avalé tout de suite lui donne au
dîner j'ai l'impression que morceau
était trop gros là je connais depuis
longtemps je connais leur budget c'est
vraiment des clients pour nous et on y
va avant pour l'instant on y va
la dynastie des ebooks résumé des
épisodes précédents
la princesse l'intérim ou quémander bois
continue de voler les pauvres pour
donner aux riches
la chasse a été fructueuse toute la raya
mérite salaire
d'accord ton salaire à toi je vais te le
faire tu vas l'avoir le plus beau jeu
tout con salir le voilà mon salaire mais
côté six ans pour mon père c'est pour la
vanité 7 7 et de 9 - coiffeur de 9
mon couturier gillett jr thor la
fougasse tu t'imagines pas que j'ai tout
petit pas pour payer ses créanciers ton
père ta famille tu as fait ta cousine
protéger voile avec toi et me lâche je
vais faire mon band aid depuis le temps
que je peux le faire je vais le faire
c'est quoi ce bordel
mon disque à disque oui et pourquoi tu
veux faire un histoire parce que tu
trouves que tu y chante bien
ma pauvre chérie je suis le rossignol le
rossignol de la méditerranée mauvais
c'est joli ce studio il évolua on a bien
fait de le piquer faire 3e steve être
chanteur devra faire de jolies chansons
ramené beaucoup d'argent et moi je serai
un imprésario entre sanaa et moroni
empresario kézaco petit robert
imprésario sorte de batraciens ventouses
qui se colle sur le dos d'une vedette de
cinéma ou de la chanson
il ne fait rien sinon qu'il partage ses
repas ses femmes et ses revenus synonyme
johnny stark ou monsieur 50% voire page
non mais ça va pas te rendre mes femmes
toi apparemment des femmes et la moitié
de ses revenus
la voiture donc je voudrais tu vois mes
dix dons en échange de conseils une
petite commission alors tu m'écoutes
mort à tuchan cela devant le micro
tu t'appliques oui tu te détends où il
fait beau sourire j'ai le trac
j'ai les boules
[Musique]
le terrain compte rue st
je peux me
tu n'as rien fait pour se relancer
ap
je t'aime pour tous
mona
on rien je le sens nouveau
défunt
je serai toujours ouvert
depuis par amour
un jour
commun
eux c'est plus fort que moi
[Musique]
te
[Applaudissements]
je chantais
m
pour fasciner ahmed hajji kim d
je chie
la dynastie des ebooks résumé des
épisodes précédents
la métamorphose de mort a été stoppé par
une attaque reprenons la suite de ce
grand feuilleton la princesse du bouc
s'évertue à changer le style de mourad
et moi au moins je suis pas à l'aise
comme satisfait comme ça c'est pas une
petite cravate qui va changer sa vie
quand même et b6 ou son chat au nom au
nom du garde l'ont reconnu pas sur mon
chapeau et justement faux pas contre
connaissent change un peu de look
le look oui quézako le look encore petit
robert look style art gothique dégaine
synonyme jeanne mas line renaud
voir page 2 18 alors je vais ressembler
à ça mais tu vas te faire un nouveau
style qui a ajouté petites boucles
d'oreilles voila voila tu es superbe tu
veux pas que tu te tapes le mourant du
bois c'est pourri pour la chanson soit
pourrait t'appeler mourareau non non non
pas amoureux se trouve en son nom à nos
espagnole alors ça tirait bien molinos
une chapelle à ce jour il n'a pas mal
maureen aussi j'appelle tu vas mettre
beaucoup plus de voiles et est charmante
et cieux je chante un dieu
non j'ai pas notre truc de champion cart
des prénoms prix
[Applaudissements]
je chantais
et enfin
pour fasciner la baie d'alger qui me
désole
je chante pour animer cet effet là
mesdames tombe au regard de femmes m
je chante
pour cette évasion gourmande de ce folie
qui nous attend
g
[Musique]
oh la la vie ni bouc
oui pour vous servir le super lot ce qu
il est les photos d'eric donne la
sixième chaîne espagnole
oui j'ai entendu les petits moreno la
lèze les chattes il est bien il est bien
mais il faudrait changer complètement
les locaux et vous savez nous allons
surtout l'accès des produits américains
j'aurais cher à ce moment dallas et
l'alliance des mouvements
le petit espagnol c'est intéressant oui
américanisé moi tout ça et vous fait
confiance et et et merci beaucoup
d'éléments ocho à lewaï pas cette fois
en phase de devenir
saga internationale nous découvrons les
concepteurs en plein travail
non je pense que nadine maintenant elle
est allée au point où elle doit
complètement changé de look sinon nous
ce feuilleton est en train de se casser
la gueule aux moments importants où on
va américanisé nadine il se casse la
gueule on va l'envoyer en espagne là bas
j'ai perdu ce que nos escales cela est
ridicule ridicule
il ya eu des personnages comme lui
voient pas tomber amoureuse un
personnage pas publier pareilles
impossible mais par contre le ps 14 h 30
pétanque personnage bestia là ils
étaient prêts à la la justement on vous
a suffi un tiens j'en vois un autre as
tu te souviens d'agbar l'amour c'est un
début un peu ambigu montignac et s'il y
avait un truc entre petit robert et
maury d'eau saline c'est une fille
gentille nadine elle n'aime pas le sexe
et la membre à ce sujet qui mens je vais
en boîte blr boisset lembras elle
embrasse cage holy crap jeu le voir en
piste
[Musique]
je vais faire un bisou quels jeux vous
bourricot je vais faire un bisou jaune
et ma clause quel joli berger allemand
j'ai fait un pic je libère un chanteur
je vais rouler une pelle je vais faire
un bisou que je les marque pages une
faire un bisou membres des voix jean
françois boucher par bis ban a écouté
des goûters arrêtées suite vous plaît
arrêter puis qui vous êtes bon monsieur
perdu trop nos qui m'envoient parce que
vous comprenez avec oui monsieur le
directeur qui m'envoient parce qu'avec
le storyboard
il fallait le dire plutôt une bonne
tenue dernière sympathique
la dynastie des ebooks
résumé des épisodes précédents la
princesse nadine ebooks ne supportant ni
moins des bois ni petit robert décide de
partir en espagne pour tenter sa chance
auprès de berlusconi
le directeur de la sixième chaîne ou bts
[Musique]
il
joby java
[Musique]
depuis damas
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais l'habit la dynamique des semis et
katie katie qui apaise les twittos prend
garde parce que toréador prend garde
mon cas n'est pas son nom c'est pas
grave tu t'occupes de tournoi peut être
ma vache est au oui depuis le temps que
je rêve tu sais cet effet la vague
chiffres dévoilés dans loelle frétille
we made you avant cela il faut que je te
présente ma belle mère
madré n'était présente ma fiancée ma
soeur la princesse des monarques ou non
mais non mais non c'est la princesse
soit des niveaux maman est une hausse en
voyant delà des problème de carburateur
le village arrivée l'épousé il aime tout
ça malheureux monde ignore comment tout
qu'est la mienne
remarquez monaco j'avais pas pensé à des
princes la dynastie des ebooks la
princesse nadine amouk et en espagne
amoureuse du beau toréador lopez dit
lolo mais tout le monde ne l'accueille
pas à bras ouverts c'est une affiche du
diamant tout briser mon coeur et assure
qu'elle a beaucoup changé ma qu'elle a
changé complètement de look elle se
transforme et le listing de croire à la
pris de court sur le perdriel
elle fait la cuisine exactement comme
toi le répit comme tout frétiller
construit par l'union sera très
malheureux marietta show made river
vieux os les gars comme la changer sa
démarche malgré les gardes et là on
dirait toi un peu maman pète un plomb
jeunes et même une petite fleur dans la
vie mais lyon toujours très mal
salut vierge marie fait que je sois
toujours riches toujours belle toujours
amoureuse de mon lolo fait que la
vieille halle crève très vite fait comme
on le lot russe et sa corrida
merci
[Musique]
c'est
[Applaudissements]
oui
m
[Musique]
new blood and me ramener la culée deux
oreilles demain dans la peine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la princesse nadine ebooks en espagne
est toujours la proie facile du toréador
lolo qui exerce sur elle une dictature
puissante et viril
alors on a des mimiques qu'est ce que tu
penses de la dernière mode espagnole
c'est un ravissant rubin la vie sans la
méchante la 10 ans bon très bien il veut
préparer ma prochaine corrida en
attendant tu va répéter avec moi les
commandements de la femme du torero
primero il n'y aura pas d'autres hommes
dans ma vie et mon mari les taux bien
secundo pas trop les errements et à
l'inspecteur est toujours ma belle-mère
à utah est au travail et même en avant
d'accomplir mon devoir conjugal
j'ai récupéré 50 pater et 50 av je ferai
50 fois mon devoir conjugal avant de
réciter un master et de passer à
caractère j'ai monté là il veut que tu
connaisses tout sa part que quand il
revient matusz a mal on verra nos mamans
c'est encore un bon coup mais qu'est ce
qu'ils me contactent familles sont plus
qu comme une fringue et tout
najim ebooks à dîner moules qu'elle pas
l'air de te revoir dit qu'est ce que tu
fais là genoux comme ça en espagne je me
durand tour adorent ils n'arrêtent pas
de le réciter des retards et des pack du
munster
mais c'est pour ça que je suis venu par
l'odeur alléché la loupe les a
longuement pourquoi ces jaloux un bout à
loulou google ou les montres betino de
schwarz vous donnent leurs à la seconde
près il est 18 heures 22 minutes 30
secondes
habituez-vous aux nouvelles télévisions
bientôt tous les programmes seront
entrecoupées par des publicités et
maintenant qu'il a un amoureux du sport
avec qui m'ont fait baver lui emmène moi
moi je veux plus rester ici mais les
jaloux c'est lucas ridge 6-1 fringué
comme ça on est là tuez web ça va
madrid avait porté un coup monté
si tu finis boucher les oreilles et la
queue et google qui vous jouer les
mamans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis que nadine amouk s'est enfui
d'espagne la vie semble plus calme
auprès de son ami le prince lui lui
allez allez allez encore des cornichons
tient leur fine à manger ses cornichons
ce n'est en vue le matin bleu quand je
me lève jamais cornichons le soir quand
je me construis cornichons la prime qui
ont tué mon 7e la voiture semble
maintenant ça grossit
quand j'ai grossi nom du matin c'est
plus qu'un gros soutien car il paie ici
voilà tu trouves que aussi gp si il faut
que je dise je me sens pas bien
le matin quand je me lève j'ai comme des
nausées tu sais le soir quand je me
couche et je me sens lourd je me sens
ballonnet si tous ses cornichons
imbéciles
ah oui j'ai pas non plus tu es pas que
lloyd of tient mauvaise mine
- ta place j'irais chez le docteur
peut-être que tu attraper une maladie
contagieuse en espagne tu as peut-être
raison lui on y va à leurs docteurs et
bien m'ont dit une bonne nouvelle vous
êtes enceinte de cinq mois
félicitations et ckoi docteur être
enceinte alors c'est grave
non lui je suis enceinte de cinq mois
bah oui enceinte de cinq mois 500 un
bébé mais c'est qui le perd on peut
surpasser le père le père c
c'est peut-être le ps 14
monde se soldent berger allemand croisé
merlin chanteur
et markit fade
bien loin des bois lopez le toréador bas
c'est toi le père c'est vrai c'est toi
mais comment ces mois puisque vu que
tous les deux on n'a jamais fait des
choses quoi à bonn en banlieue on est
obligé de faire des choses ensemble faut
avoir un bébé un rebond peut arriver
comme ça je suis content j'espère qu on
m'aurait semblé ça non plus j'ai pas
pensé à moi aussi j'espère un bébé allez
viens on va jeter des cornichons parce
qu'on considère mire la dynastie des
ebooks
la princesse a denim ou qu attend un
bébé
et l'échéance se rapproche le prince lui
lui père présumé enfin présume-t-il
attend avec elle
gmail un peu tenu coûte quand même mais
je t'en prie vie dont j'ai mal je te dis
mais forcément tous les cornichons et
les frais ce que tu t'en vois maintenant
en tout cas pas mal alors si tu fout
quoi les commissions les presque excuses
en avoir c'est le petit qui m'a même si
ça fait six mois que tu le sais mais
premières douleurs et ben respire
comment tu as appris comme le dr dazé
respire comme le chien il a du même coup
que je préfère aller au filet
[Musique]
un docteur je sors tes joues et oui oui
qui sortent à laisser pousser nous je
sais pas la dame est sous emprise
je le vois d'où ça vient
j'espère qu'il va être bon monfils 7e
garcia je crois bon je crois estrat soir
un garçon monte en régime et non non
pourquoi parce qu'il est caché
bon il est fâché c'est pas ça te faire à
sa tête il va avoir froid il me semble
je t'en prie parle pas de chose comme ça
une quelconque couture prix enfin on
n'est pas là pour rigoler voilà mes
cousins au sérieux la famille des
brassées mes cousins services et les
fromages qui soutient paul et jean mages
ils sont rois et son roi d'une petite
localité bourgeonner rois mages
aïe ça parce qu'il est non au bout d'un
boudin c'est joli non résolu mais enfin
bon
à mon avis c'est la famille qui
s'inquiète là je suis sûr
[Musique]
hiriart prenez pas dans la purée leroy
merlin qu'on les ait ce sanguinaire ce
faux il veut tuer mon petit il n'aime
pas la compétition je vais pas le dire
et la jenny mot puisque un truc comme ça
elle est capable de faire une fausse
couche
enfin maintenant je lui dis pas quand
même motus et bouche cousue
je veux voir mon
[Musique]
et chanter les spectateurs nous voici
donc sur devant le perron de la clinique
mal védère nous allons essayer de savoir
si réellement il y à un nouveau venu
dans la famille princière ebooks alors
tout de suite on va essayer d'en savoir
un peu plus nous nous dirigeons vers les
chambres pour savoir si le nouveau né
est arrivé bien voilà tout de suite
tombé le premier salon alors est ce
qu'il ya un nouveau venu dans la
dynastie
c'est un garçon bon et il bosse je n'ai
pas vu encore seule la princesse a eu le
droit de voir son enfant lui paraît
qu'il est très beau il pèse combien il
est assez fort
ils vous ressemblent où il paraît que si
tout mon visage a déjà les moustaches
tout s'est bien passé docteur très bien
très bien
la présence de jean en ce moment se
repose alors vous n'aurez pas d'autre
déclaration laisse pas nous voulions
rassurer la presse unanime et
heureusement on tient absolument pour
nous téléspectateurs à avoir quand même
se met avant un fils je crois nous avons
un fils et je peux vous assurer qu'ils
se portent bien la princesse aussi la
dynastie des ebooks est heureuse et
d'autres cousins docteur jean sort vous
nous confirmer c'est bien office je
crois oui je vous en prie ça suffit s'il
vous plaît ne soyez pas non ça suffit
une déclaration
si je fais
[Musique]
le lissage de la gueule et j'ai la
berlusconi c'est pas possible on
enlevait maladie de mon fils n'est pas
un gameiro ça sent le souffre reims
nîmes
vous êtes un grossier personnage bâtard
furoncle de la fonction publique
j'enlève naji niveau et mon fils est
votre pâte un bâtard trois mêmes afin
qu'il n'y ait pas de rester sur le trône
du mot à salon bett porteront sont
acceptés pas question là c'est ce qu'on
verra malade j
[Musique]
vous pouvez compter sur l'inspecteur
vinaigre je m'en occupe
[Musique]
fois au royaume des imik la princesse
n'a dit ni mook a eu un bébé
le père présumé et le prince lui mais au
stupeur le roi mais rob jaloux de
l'héritier enlève nadine ebooks
le prince lui fait appel à l'inspecteur
vinaigre mon cher le lui comme tu dois
déjà le savoir j'ai été enlevé par mes
robes tout va bien
le petit est sage et gâter mes robes lui
a acheté toutes ses petites affaires
c'est des vacances pour me je t'envoie
la photo de temps piccione au qui pour
homme qu'il est peu près rien mis des
lunettes déjà alors il s'appelle léon
comme tu le souhaitait parce que j'ai
toujours voulu à bien total a dit est
empilé on attend et un vaisseau
christophe je mange bien j'ai pris un
kilo
on va les retrouver nous tu va me suivre
en mesure de répéter tout ce que je dis
chaque fois imbéciles
oui
regarde regard et à moutarde sénat jean
la voilà c'est m man a dit mme harel ma
beauté mon bijou ma princesse
ce qui fait plaisir c'est qu'on voit
qu'elle perd de sa vitalité et son
dynamisme la rentrée sortir il en fera
la peinture au lit il a pas l'air
méchant il n'a pas l'air méchant à y
aller un peu bougon un peu d'accord mais
ils n'ont pas aidé pas tous les jours
rigoler avec elle at elle a son
caractère
un videur est serrée 1 elle est pour
mais quand même je t'explique et najim
c'est une femme enfant dans toute sa
splendeur
ni elle aime son fils mon fils aussi
elle fera tout pour lui pour la tête du
puits a été levée dans tout cela mais
nadine ebooks
commenter ces échanges les plans ils
s'envoient il faut les suivre
allez canigou en cuir chez moi
[Musique]
l'europe tapis qck derrière
enfin le principe et l'inspecteur
vinaigre ont repéré des mimiques enlevé
par l'affreux mayrand une poursuite sans
pitié s'engage
car mes robes n'hésite pas à lancer ses
hommes de main dans cet endroit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est c'est obliger l'ati
mais qui vont suivre des salles et j'ai
compris
si les deux chats ou je te rends mes
rêves vont regarder du coin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
je suis diminué
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après une poursuite infernale
le prince lui lui et l'inspecteur
vinaigre retrouve à nouveau la voiture
de mes robes dans laquelle est tenue
prisonnière
nadine est mou serait bien qu'on prenne
le métro pour bébé mais il est un petit
peu autre chose
un numéro balle et on va prendre le
métro maintenant
[Musique]
tu m'aurais dit mais rendu de trouver
dans métro avec toi
elle soit
le petit est le petit
veillez à bord 10 heures d'attentes
aumeyras c'est qu'il fait peur avec
tabac à l'effet le sourire à bhl mais b
j'ai bien compris un ce docteur vinaigre
la technique du camouflage nous le sens
pas l'âme
là
[Musique]
mais difficile à dîner pour un petit
du coin
elle a l'air tendu m
mais reversant la souffrance sur son
visage en fait sur sonic 1 calmez vous
calmez vous rirez jours au calme et
futurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
médor mayrand nero lui
[Musique]
mero du roman man à jinro moi ma fleur
jamais comment ça
j'avais en moi ma fleur du souffle à
theix et armes à feu vous causez des
fusils mais c'est écrit dans le scénario
tout à l'heure vous n'aviez pas de
suisse va peut être encore du tout haut
mais qu'est ce que tu vas commencer à
compliquer les choses doit à ses écrits
ses écrits une puis deux prochains mois
même temps qu'est ce tu fais avec ce
simple mais fait ce qu'il veut avec son
cintre son problème
en tout cas nous on respecte le
téléspectateur
dis moi c'est que je joue aujourd'hui
vendredi 6 heures excusez moi je peux
pas c'est shabbat avec jacques ces trucs
tu peux pas savoir
enfin débarrassé de l'infâme mes robes
la princesse nadine ebooks élus sont
prêts pour de nouvelles aventures
on mesure d'apporter ça c'est une
championne mondiale à sa cellule
qu'est ce que tu manges a non seulement
pour but le bourg notamment se prépare
un portrait de lui lui c'est moi
[Musique]
la visite gentil garden où le peu de
bruit vous et on va travailler on est
assez d'accord c'est bien mais les
sucettes à l'anis ou plus de soigner je
fais vraiment le choix
on peut le voter qu'est ce que je n'aime
pas c'est tata pompiers ont écouté les
deux sets à fait ponctuel m'énerve
période sont en pompier mais le départ
pour le petit est bien le mot peau du
petit dit il faudrait penser à les voir
monsieur le curé pour le baptême fort
monsieur le curé
[Musique]
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que c'est une pure
et je parlais de curé à l'instant et
puis moi j'ai fait à l'épuré c'est toi
tu crois peut-être récidiver tu disais
par exemple le baigneur kadji baigneaux
je suis comme ça j'ai du baigneur et ça
marche
alors posez pas le nez c'est le pompon
ça va remplir bien élevé contre la
région commence vers lui avec mon dont
cinq comme telle et j'ai plus besoin
d'aller chez le tailleur chaque fin juin
caussieu à l'équipe bush du croupion et
royan costumes taux n'a pas d'ambition
obtient gagnent petit tu sais ce que je
vais faire mon ambition
oui tu vas aller voir bernard moquette
bernard hinault kate lui monde on va
l'intéresser tu vas voir lui je vais lui
montrer mon don et voir ce qu'il va en
faire
tiens j'y vais d'ailleurs entre les
mains moi je reste comme ça
[Musique]
résumé des épisodes précédents en se
dandinant par hasard la princesse nadine
ebooks découvre qu'elle a un don
surprenant elle peut transformer
l'apparence physique de son entourage
cette nouvelle bien aimé décidé
d'exploiter son don en allant voir
bernard moquette vous êtes des tâches
vous êtes des mulets et vous le savez
c'est bien c'est déjà bien déjà un
premier pas vous avez couler votre
propre entreprise
alors si vous êtes aujourd'hui chez
bernard moquette
c'est pour devenir les battants de
demain on de devenir les les gagneurs
les gagnants alors vous allez bien
l'écouter parce que pour devenir les
battantes demain c'est pas simple et des
conseils à suivre
je voulais donner ses conseils réussir
sa vie
c'est croire en la star
où tout est magie
ou tu gérant
[Musique]
c'est très malsain
l'océan
sans savoir pourquoi ni coquille
tout ça
ne cherchez plus beaux imoca je suis
celle qui vous forêts moselle qui êtes
vous non mais écoutez nous sommes en a
dedans j dont nous sommes en pleine
séance de travail
j'apprends à ses jours je leur apprend à
devenir des gagnants des bateaux mais
oui mais grâce à mon sens ils vont
devenir des battants non au couteau vous
êtes gentils vous retournez chez votre
maman ou chez votre belle maman et vous
ne foutez là vous avez observé monde ont
regardé le bien
[Musique]
mais qu'avez vous fait la ribot doux et
m'avoir de nous sommes employés bien
quoi qu on vient de reconnaître la des
dons vite on fait
[Musique]
ça y est enfin la princesse denim hook
va connaître la notoriété grâce à
bernard moquette qui lui aussi a été
séduit par son don
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
édition numéro trois comptoirs bonsoir à
toutes et à tous édition numéro 3 ce
soir d'arrivisme l'émission que vous
aimez parce qu'elle découvre de nouveaux
talents il n'y a pas qu'aux états unis
que les gens ont du talent et des idées
non ici aussi nous en avons alors nous
allons très vite rentré dans le vif du
sujet équipes de marketing est prête les
banquiers sont prêts en face de moi et
puis l'équipe de publicité et là va
donner tout à l'heure des conseils à
celle bixi d'une femme qui va venir nous
montrer ses talents
je vous la présente sans plus tarder
j'ai le plaisir d'appeler la princesse
nadine amouk on l'applaudît
bonsoir ça va bonsoir princesse nous
sommes nous sommes très heureux de vous
accueillir ici ce soir sur le plateau
d'harry vise moi même aussi je suis très
heureuse de participer à cette émission
de vous montrer mandon alors vous allez
nous montrer votre don dans quelques
instants
vous allez vous vous présentez un petit
peu pour les téléspectateurs et bien je
suis évidemment la princesse célèbre
nadine amouk j'ai un enfant qui
ressemble terriblement à son père lui
lui un enfant qui s'appelle les au repas
faire repas faire de la publicité pour
les autres elle adore la publicité qui
va faire d'ailleurs les commentaires du
bon goût c'est très bien elle adore la
publicité ça démarre pas mal oui
l'équipe militaire là je crois qu'elle
va être assez doué alors nadine est ce
que vous pensez qu'avec votre don vous
allait révolutionner la matière que vous
présenter ce soir
écoutez la matière que je vous présenter
ce soir est ce qu'on appelle la matière
la plus blanche la plus charnue de mon
corps c'est comme le poulet
et la folie vous prétendez que vous
pouvez me transformer so lu ment très
bien me l'aurait pas à ce que vous
ressemblez alors et cela en bougeant
votre ouïe très bien entre rappeurs
attrapé trappeur de l'ouest chez vous
transforme tout de suite un trappeur de
l'ouest a il faut un petit peu se
concentrer on l'applaudît très fort
parce que quelquefois les candidats sont
un petit peu froid
on n'essaie rien par un petit peu c'est
qu'en le faisant à 2 c
voulait être une bourde vous m'avez
ridiculiser arrivisme ont des missions
alors la maintenance et c'est dans le
lac
mehdi dont j'ai bien réussi à
transformer toute la salle entre
rappeurs et les cameramen en trapèze
on s'en fout des cameramans on s'en fout
de la salle c'est moi qu'on attendait
entre appert de l'ouest et on a eu quoi
vers la moquette pipette abera moquette
pipette
et bien hier d'un vocable si ces people
j'irai proposé monde en amérique
centrale ont du sens du vent ni le
castel et monsieur moquette sait tenir
un homme offre
oui un homme saluer le héros
désemparé après son échec avec bernard
moquette nadine ebooks va se réfugier
chez le grand lama du soleil levant haut
que tu es beau grand que tu es beau dans
la lumière de ce soleil levant que
j'aime ton corps chaud brûlant verne
d'autres nuit était divine grands lamas
j'aimerais bien de recommencer toute la
journée
le bain le corps du la main il est crevé
ne s'imagine pas que toutes les nuits si
tu viens pendant pendant deux ans
relaxer et te détendre avec moi ne
t'imagines pas toutes les nuits vont
être des nuits de l'info manie comme ça
vient de se passer
mais qu'est ce que tu fais dans cette
position dans l'âme je dis dans mes
muscles fatigué fatigué par cette nuit
de bed breizh
qu'ai je fait au ciel qu'ai je fait pour
tomber amoureux d'un aide
dont l'essence ne sont
satisfait
qu'après plusieurs heures de bien-être
je suis appelé je suis crevée
et de nuit en nuit je mets tu y as le g
bon manger hermange et je perds un kilo
par soirée
je crois bien
qu'elle ne dort jamais
tu ne penses cote en bourse est pas
possible lâche moins un peu la sto se
reposer surtout que maintenant c'est
l'heure d'admirer le nombre in tout le
monde ici admire le nombril du grand
lama regarde pour tous les boutons aubry
que je te dise talent même nombril que
l'empereur napoléon forcément là m'a
appelé on vous avez été nombreux à nous
écrire et à vous poser des questions
concernant la psychologie des
personnages de cette grande saga les
célèbres héros de ce grand péplum sont
prêts à vous répondre
prince lui avait vu autant de coeur que
vous laisser paraître et bien sûr rien
si j'avais pas du coeur je serai pas là
pour répondre princesse ma denim ou qu
avez-vous une conscience j'en avais
marre vous ranger avant qu'un gros mis à
mon avis il a mis dans les malles prince
lui êtes vous sûr d'être le père de
votre enfant alors que vous n'avez eu
aucune relation sexuelle avec la
princesse nadine ça commence la
médisance et le sexe hors d'axa qui vous
intéresse le tambour on n'est pas obligé
de faire du tambour pour avoir des
enfants
non c'est vraiment les ans et mon fils
ça je le reconnais mais aux princesses
un denim ou que vous avez connu beaucoup
d'hommes énormément il y en at il un que
vous garder en souvenir que j'ai
particulièrement aimé je devais le dire
enfin je préfère me ressaisir quelqu'un
pour que j'ai failli me suicider au
moins quatre fois
comment s'appelait-il si vous croyez je
me rappelle comme ils s'appellent il
était plomb on prend il avait les yeux
but non anglaise le noir prince lui est
ce vraiment votre enfant puisqu'il est
noir le noir ce une couleurs de l'arc en
ciel
alors et puis je dois dire qu on aime
beaucoup l'aimer pimenté managing moi il
est un peu moins nos dignes quand je
vous dis concombres
vous pensez à quoi ma mère pourquoi
parce qu'elle était fan du concombre
si je vous dis chocolat vous dites quoi
rambo pourquoi c'est si je vous dis
tomates rouges
donc voilà pourquoi le chocolat ou
encore moins quand je vous dis chocolat
pourquoi bon chocolat
si je vous dis sexe et puis pourquoi
parce que ça paie qu'une épine si je
vous dis mégots montagne vous ne
demandez pas pourquoi nom de l' aventure
du suspense
de l'amour du sexe de la violence
quiproquos du sexe
du rêve de l'exotisme des paysages
somptueux des interprètes prestigieux
une aventure à vous couper le souffle
un suspense sans précédent dans
l'histoire de la télévision des cayron
qui n'ont peur de rien des intrigues
familiales où l'argent est roi où
l'honneur est pas fou et où les
protagonistes de cette grande saga sont
sans pudeur ne manquaient pas
prochainement sur vos écrans
le retour de nadine ebooks toujours sans
nouvelles de la princesse d'unimilk
le prince lui acquis et part à sa
recherche
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur je cherche ma ma
fiancée la princesse n'a dit ni mo s est
pas ici du tout monsieur ici c'est le
cimetière d'éléphants
c'est un truc de la télé dans les
vallées va aller barrages et les
voitures angers des voitures mais moi je
vais la chercher
vous avez dit lundi niveaux jamais vus
espèce de dury toi rangez les voitures
âgées les voitures les frères les prends
pour moi j'ai recherché lundi
[Musique]